when I was a kid there wasn't a lot of
spare money in our house to spend on
fancy ingredients but mum was brilliant
at what she did let me tell you so we
had really tasty hearty food great cakes
amazing puddings all made with the
freshest ingredients that's right isn't
it yes
let's get this shoe on their own come
we're cooking the kind of food mum
always dished up starting with a family
favorite steamed date pudding with a
glorious butterscotch sauce
they weren't called desserts on those
days were they no it was puddings
puddings now I'm gonna sieve a flour
would you ouch up here Shawna chop those
dates please it was a favorite wasn't it
amazing sew it in
okay but it's almost like an
old-fashioned dessert
and everything was sort of steam you had
Jam roly-poly
so the zest or the orange makes that
really nice and fragrant sort of helps
get that richness of the suit
okay yeah
brown sugar in
such an easy recipe yes looks fantastic
on the table
and then treacle
in look at that
there's something quite
magical about a spoonful of treacle can
you add them in there please thank you
and crack an egg
lightly whisk it and mix that into the
milk
if I pour in the egg and the milk would
you give that little mix up please yeah
thank you
nice
it's a little
don't go too fast
you see I always just think that it was
an old-fashioned dessert steamed pudding
do you ever remember me tumbling around
your knees trying to sort of get in
there yeah so you like to lick the ball
didn't you all the time
now lightly Grease the mold you're
always willing to help
but not with washing up some things
never change I think I was allergic to
the soap that was your excuse
will enjoy this tonight wouldn't they
yeah delicious paper
that goes on so the secret behind the
parchment paper is keep that nice and
tight tight yep
there we are
good yeah oh okay I washed my hand
come on tightly covered with foil and
placing a pan of water and let it Steam
for around two hours with a lid on
are you going to worship God
just for once worship
oh dear goodness
you let that smash
um you handed it to me and he dropped it
come on whilst mum forces me to break
the habit of a lifetime dear that's the
thought of you washing up it does that
to you here's how to make an amazing
butterscotch sauce to serve with the
pudding
add butter into a pan
brown sugar
golden syrup
and a pinch of salt
and vanilla seeds
melt and combine over a medium Heat
stir in the cream and simmer until
thickened
that's the taste of my childhood in a
jug right there and it will keep in the
fridge for a week
[Music]
the main course my all-time favorite
shepherd's pie what's the secret
behind a really good
shepherd's pie
I would think the vegetables you use
so we're gonna use leeks and onions and
start Browning off the mince you know no
color no flavor I've never forgotten
that you know that yep
so
I'm going to have color gotta have color
otherwise it puts that gray tinge on the
shepherd's pie that looks greasy and
cheap and nasty
we don't want that do we and I know you
don't do cheaper nasty let me clear your
peelings now ah all right thank you very
much there's no Nails in there now is
there no
chicken
I remember your
amazing shepherd's pie and that lovely
little restaurant used to work in in
sheep Street in Stratford Haven so you
never got food sent back
no one times have complained that there
wasn't enough come on no I'm tempting
you never ever got a complaint no
how long did you work at that restaurant
for
six years six years
what are you cooking I'm gonna make okay
I saw the modern version of Nana's
shepherd's pie I shouldn't Manny be
doing the cooking because she's the best
to cook excuse me
would you top our onion please Danny
yeah oh gosh your eyes are gonna water
um
that's in this spot sorry in there we've
got a delicious steamed treatment date
pudding
[Music]
how do skeletons call their friends I'm
not too sure on the scalable on the
skele come on okay so two cats are in a
race one is called one two three and the
other is cool
thanks
oh goodness tells why are you making ice
cream cup of Chip and Annie
thank you bye so give that a little fry
off okay
nice
Portuguese jokes they get worse gosh
she's only having a bit of fun what's
the sauce that's gonna give that a
really nice spicy seasoning
okay yeah
tomato puree
you could put a tomato matters in this
if you want you could yeah
put that mince back in there once it's
drained
I'm just going to put a little touch I
know you'll go crazy at this a little
touch of red wine
really yeah
well because I'm going to make it nice
and Rich
okay reduce the red wine down yeah and
then start covering your mints
with your stock
now I'm gonna bring it up to the ball
okay and then get some fresh Rosemary
okay like a little taste yes
it's a little bit hot be careful
well either way
sorry
oh God
all right as it Cooks the house the wine
and the alcohol disappear it'll be
delicious trust me now go on spring
onions we'll chop up
and that's going to go through the
mashed potatoes it's gonna sit on top of
that nice I like that savory yeah
delicious mince it's laced with all that
red wine nice so Springer is into there
Please Mum
[Applause]
yeah so I'm gonna dry out those potatoes
and then mash them
would you
um Holly slice a little knob of butter
in there for Jack please
so what was the restaurant you want
you want cook
I love the diplomacy well you're a chef
I was a cook
exactly that
yeah
you kids do no potatoes
These are nice and fluffy aren't they
aren't they and you want them look
delicious mashed potatoes yeah with no
lumps in there
[Laughter]
it's great having you back in the
kitchen Mommy now yeah seriously brings
back good
man just why'd you do that Dad I just
wanted to Fork it to get it nice and
spiky
so I want that nice crispy topping
and then lightly grate that cheddar
cheese on top and that goes in the oven
literally 20 minutes 180. Jack can you
open the door please
doesn't it even though you said you
didn't like it earlier okay
back in the day Mama's meals all came
with two veg and this is no different
but with a modern twist braised peas and
carrots with a fantastic homemade mint
butter
shepherd's pie
glazed on top that looks lovely doesn't
it doesn't it and then the carrots
so you did carrots that's why I didn't
put carrots in let's put them on the
side I see last job before serving pour
that gorgeous butterscotch sauce over
the pudding
I'm gonna take one at a time that smells
incredible
this is my ultimate childhood dinner
shepherd's pie with crispy cheese champ
topping sweet buttery peas and carrots
and a steamed date pudding dripping in
butterscotch sauce all that's missing
are the family on the menu is a
succulent rare beef fillet with salsa
Valley served with roasted truffle new
potatoes the dish is designed to make
your special occasion one to remember
and to end our Ramsay get together with
a bang I've enlisted willing sous chef
Jack to help me make us a blind
chocolate and pistachio semifredo
I know you love chocolate right
we'll break this up so it melts nice and
evenly
all right that goes over bammary you
can't put the chocolate in direct
contact with the gas yeah okay otherwise
it will split crack four eggs in there
and please one of course hold one like
that on the side and then your fingers
in
and pull out okay because
nice now you're cracking eggs with one
hand hey
nice one I need some muscles okay start
whisking and I'll fold in a bit of sugar
come on let's do 30 seconds each ready
okay come on Jack give it some 13 year
old Welly come on some muscles
10 seconds to go nine eight seven six
five four three two one right here go
your temperature let's go
you see the secret to whisking
vigorously is changing your hands every
10 seconds yep you're not gonna stir the
chocolate I'll start
now the secret behind this is getting it
really nice and thick and that's like
your stab it on okay your turn come on
Chase change again yeah of course also
the chocolate leave that to slightly
cool down a touch
from there
cream in
why put in the cream in separately
because I'm gonna get it nice and thick
first if you start whisking that I'm
going to get in the vanilla to maximize
the flavor from a vanilla bean Cut the
pot in half lengthways and scrape out
those wonderfully aromatic seeds
for extra flavor put the pod in as well
but remember to take it out once it's
infused
so we've got three components for melted
chocolate yes sugar yes and the eggs
whipped up and the cream with the
vanilla
next mix in your melted chocolate with
the sugar and egg Sabayon so you've got
a nice rich chocolate ganache smell how
delicious that is
I'm now I'm putting the cream and so you
just
now look at that how gorgeous is that
looking and that my son is a chocolate
semifreddo now a little taste
[Music]
pistachios right sprinkle them in
now get your bacon train you line that
with clean film so it's easy to pull out
once it sets and then just pull that in
it's a real treat
so you fold that over okay this this is
like ice cream in any way yeah as it
sets slices like this nice chocolate ice
block delicious
then put your semifredo into the freezer
for around three hours to set
right jack get that pan nice and hot
recognize that fillet of beef this is a
Rolls-Royce not beef so we've got to
treat it with some respect okay yeah mop
up all that seasoning here into the pan
and get that really nice and hot hello
teals
my kiss and
what's that holes what's the name
Rosemary a little bit of garlic and
Thyme in there
cooking with these aromatic herbs and
garlic will add flavor to the beef
because it's a fillet of beef
there's hardly any fat on there so you
sear it quickly ends as well get seared
I'm gonna now put some butter in there
continue frying all those herbs now
baste that with the butter see no no
we're just having this or we're gonna
have something with it now we'll just
have some beautiful baked potatoes with
truffle and a salsa verde into the oven
eight to ten minutes that's all
next my super special bake new potatoes
wash and drain small new potatoes and
dip into a bacon tray
drizzle with olive oil then season with
a touch of salt and freshly ground black
pepper Place into an oven preheated at
180 degrees Celsius and bake for 35
minutes until crisp on the outside and
soft all the way through
transfer to your serving dish and Grate
over fresh Parmesan cheese
last but not least shave gorgeous earthy
black truffle slivers onto the cheesy
potatoes
baking potatoes with a lavish twist
indulgent but couldn't be simpler to
make
right salsa birthday anchovies little
touch of anchovy oil in there okay
after that we've got some capers
garlic
in with the anchovies and the Capers
okay A Touch
of salt whining a touch because you
could have solved me after these that's
right Dijon mustard
vinegar give it a nice mix and now this
is where it starts to go to a completely
different level some fresh mint and some
fresh parsley I want half of it in there
pureed a touch of olive oil in there in
the rest of the mint
salt pepper
excited
no taste
I'd love something
what's it taste like fat
you might need to try a tiny bit more
just to check stop don't kiss any boys
now
before the kids polish off all the cells
available I need a distraction and I
think my B fillet will do the job nicely
look at this baby hot holes
up
look at that
says and look how juicy and tender that
is take that out and let that sit on the
a little spoon just while it sits and
rests off your South severely as the
beef cools down that's salsa verde
marinades that goes the table very
carefully please Tails taking over the
baked potatoes please right semi Friday
now
look at that it's nice
wow and then you just get the chocolate
and they're grate it
[Music]
it's gorgeous
how delicious is that let's go with Do
not drop that please going up to my
bedroom now Jack
this is my ultimate special occasion
dinner the tenderest rare beef fillet
with Punchy salsa verde
served with extravagant truffle new
potatoes
and a Sublime chocolate and pistachio
semifredo